hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the sixth of June and you're watching
game [ __ ] knees with your Australian
hosts in our San Francisco office yes I
know it's confusing but here's the
things that mattered in video games
today first up bungee have filed a
trademark for rise of iron which is
rumored to be the title of the next
destiny expansion IGN spotted the
trademark which was filed on mate 31 and
covers video games graphic novels toys
and for some reason Halloween costumes a
couple of weeks ago kotaku leaked a
poster which also suggested that the
expansion will be called rights of iron
and their source is also indicated that
the upcoming destiny content will
include a new raid and a new weapon type
the leak said that the upcoming
expansion will be larger than the dark
below and house of wolves Destiny's
first two expansions last week Bungie
announced they are planning a destiny
revealed stream for Thursday june nine
at ten a.m. PT where they plan to unveil
what's coming up next for your guardians
in destiny so stay tuned for an official
reveal square enix have revealed they're
bringing a final fantasy 12 remaster to
the ps4 entitled final fantasy 12 the
Zodiac age the game originally came out
for the ps2 in 2006 and the remaster
will arrive in Japan in 2017 no Western
release has been announced as yet jewel
shockers have reported that the ps4
version will feature higher fidelity
backgrounds character models and
cutscenes as well as support for 7.1
surround sound on top of that players
will be able to choose between Japanese
and English voices and you can also
decide to hear original music all the
rerecorded score Square Enix have said
that loading times will be shortened an
autosave feature has been added and the
game's turbo mode is being improved III
may be just around the corner but we
still have time to squeeze in yet
another delay as sony has announced that
horizon zero dawn won't be out till 2017
the hotly-anticipated ps4 exclusive from
Killzone dev Guerrilla Games is now
slated to arrive on februari 28 of neck
to you gorilla managing director Herman
Hulst explained it wasn't an easy choice
to make however we also want to ensure
that horizon zero dawn lives up to the
visuals and gameplay quality that our
games are known for the new date affords
us the extra time required to deliver
fully on our ambitious vision for
horizon zero dawn fortunately a new
trailer has been released to cushion the
blow horizon zero dawn is slated to have
a full day night cycle no multiplayer
mode a female protagonist called alloy
and most importantly robot dinosaurs let
me know down in that comment section how
you feel about the horizon zero dawn
delay and be sure to head to gamespot
where we've got news on the cancellation
of allison road and psychonauts
appearing on ps4 that is everything I
have you today bat do stay tuned for all
the newsie bits and pieces on the road
to e3 and I will capture again soon
you